évidemment ces hommes qui fait qui fait
rêver imaginer vous réveillez le matin
et vous avez 190 millions de plus à
votre compte alors on vous a demandé
forcément à votre charge du coeur ce que
vous voyez que l'argent alors
m'attendais à des choses qui font qu'ils
font rêver pas du tout même du musée
michaud qui y est à notre avis à des
jets privés des beaux hôtels et melba
pas du sceau du taux limite votre goût
[Applaudissements]
déjà jeudi je donne rien à personne
[Rires]
les associations tout ça non la vérité
j'achèterais une jet privé ça ça me
plairait beaucoup à nous amène tout le
monde
j'aime ça c'est facile l'extrême à
raymond qu'elle voyait mais qui soit 4
ans d'histoire moi je pense qu'elle me
fait plaisir
les proches les proches à l'abri
j'achèterai des voitures de sport sans
que ce soit des grosses voitures de
sport mais deux des quatre cadets des
trucs bien pour me faire plaisir des
belles maisons
après j'aurai besoin d'exister je pense
j'aurai besoin de faire des choses donc
comme bernard je vais vous savez avec
114 riba on est juste bien comme quoi
chez tu travailles puis tu fous plus
rien de sexiste alors après tu tires tu
en vois des enfants en vacances tu vas
dans ta tête des autistes des handicapés
et tu fait exister comme ça au regard
des enfants je te fait exister en fait
je dis voilà j'existe sinon si tu rends
pas l'argent il va juste superstitieux
va m'arriver amador et adoré parce que
vous êtes très raide vous dit si je
gagne donc 190 millions à l'euro
millions
je m'achète une clinique esthétique oui
alors à tout pour ma gueule c'est dire
que moi je ferai esthétique pour faire
tous les petits travaux comme ça de
retouches comme ça dès que ça tombe ça
je pique je remet alors à l'hôpital il
ya déjà un peu de travaux comme ça à
boire 1
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas des lâches et 590 millions et
ensuite j'achète un hôpital comme ça dès
que je tombe malade
moi je peux faire c'est pas ma réaction
alors alors découdra sera daniel qu'est
ce que vous pourriez en fait je me
demanderais une chambre à une suite à
l'année ou dans un grand parc
d'attractions vous savez celui avec les
oreilles on a bien vivre là bas mais
vous rendez compte vous rentrer le soir
oui vous avez un an a mais moi j'aurai
la belle au bois dormant
toute ma vie je dors là bas je deviens
alors ils achètent avec un petit je suis
quelqu'un va venir faire un bisou de
voir alors évidemment autour du loto il
ya plein d'histoires été un fantastique
rennes des histoires horribles ya un
canadien qui vient cette histoire
ils n'arrivent pour valider son billet
de loto au lot au loto c'est ils
arrivent ils arrivent en limite de temps
il ya un qui passe à la bonne heure et
ce d'après à cette seconde en retard et
c'est deuxième quinté gagnant il est
passé à côté de 27 millions de 18
millions d'euros à la seconde ça fait
très cher lacaune rien alors messieurs
c'est horrible c'est horrible oui
qu'est-ce qu'il ya je n'ai pas demandé
mais quand même
non mais vous vous souvenez pas d'un
reportage de france 2 seront gagnants de
loto qui avait gagné une somme énorme
ils lui disent mais il faut qu'on tourne
la scène pour faire drôle retourne chez
le même libraire fâché le même pain là
et puis tu rejoues tu reprends un ticket
on fait comme si tu avais gagné et bien
le mec il regagne la même somme